vous devenez voyez c'est mal venez
briché un autre train
le bridge est un jeux call et meurt
le bridge est adorable
mais monsieur je ne suis pas très forte
comment est de ma faute
ça ne fait rien eu tout capote si vous
gaver nous fermerons asseyez vous ne
pouvez pas et qu'on fait c'est moi qui
donne et wii fit plus et wii
un pitch as de carreau 300 à tout à soi
dans l ouest
c'est fou mais je ne puis admettre qu'on
me coupe quand je suis m il s'est dans
la forte du mans font jour on ne rien
compromettre
et puis il existe une règle dans sa
longueur on joue sa faible voyons
mademoiselle à quoi pensiez-vous
quand on n'a qu'à nous petit jeu de rien
du tout on ne manque pas 320 messieurs
c'était pour être aimable que j'ai pris
place à votre table le bridge est un jeu
qui m'a or le bridge est détestable
d'abord permettez que je vous explique
pourquoi j'ai joué mon avis c'est que
j'ai cru coup tu l'as cannes de coeur et
vous n'allez tout de même pas mal de roi
et pourra petit valet voudra de moi
nous avions perdu là c'est mauvais vous
n'avez pas besoin de faire en scène
allez pour qu'on vous laisse on s'écarte
jamais si c'est chez vos cils et aux
pupilles quand on a des yeux aussi 12
même avec un tout petit je veux rien
demandé 4
les nîmois bars de grave
1 400 à tous